do you know what is the highest driver  you know is the highest driver  the highest driver my experience has  been purely pride  pride in what  pride in your last name  okay which is passed down from your  parents  pride in your nationality your heritage  you have to have pride in that that's  your blood you have me whatever people  say you still have to have pride in that  pride in your industry what you do as a  trade you have to have a lot of pride in  your trade whatever i don't care what  you do you gotta have pride in your  trade and constantly get better pride in  your community  pride in your family pride in your  country  you can everything is about  representation  this there's only one of this in the  world okay and that's you how you  represent yourself to the world  eventually one day they're going to sit  there and say  i tell you man i'm just this mad guy man  who was a freaking badass yeah look  you know respect salute